in the plan to immediately provide ten
thousand dollars in debt relief as
stimulus right now the legislation
passed by the Democratic house calls for
immediate ten thousand dollar
forgiveness of student loan it should be
done immediately I am considering
dealing with some debt reduction I am
not considering fifty thousand dollars
debt reduction but I'm in the process of
taking a hard look at whether or not
there are gonna there will be additional
debt forgiveness we're close to making a
decision on students
yes President Biden expected to keep his
word on canceling student debt so get
ready to subsidize someone's useless
liberal arts degree he said to announce
a major decision to erase ten thousand
dollars of student loans for earners
making less than a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars per year it's a
lot it's a move that won't actually
erase debt but instead transfer the
burden to you the taxpayer even some
Libs think it's a bad idea as Obama's
treasury secretary Larry Summers points
out quote student loan debt relief is
spending that raises demand and
increases inflation
it consumes resources that could be
better used helping those who did not
for whatever reason have the chance to
attend college it will also tend to be
inflationary by raising tuitions Biden's
White House spin team trying to downplay
that narrative
there's been a lot of commentary raised
about potential inflationary effects of
debt cancellation I think what you
really have to do when you're measuring
this out is look at debt cancellation
but also look at debt restart that is
the end of the pause restarting payments
uh both of those have to be factored in
when you're trying to understand the
fiscal impact on overall inflation but
Biden's plan isn't good enough for the
far left Squad member Corey Bush
sounding off student debt is nearly two
trillion dollar crisis POTUS must
hashtag cancel student debt all of it
but everybody should be seeing this for
what it is a bribe young voters have
soured on Biden's presidency a pathetic
21 of 18 to 30 year olds give them a
stamp of approval so is this just a
quick way for Joe to win him back Dana I
mean if you take out a loan and if you
vote for a Democrat you might get that
loan paid back this is uh we knew that
this was coming because the the
president kept kicking the can down the
road even he has said this is just for
politics he said last January everybody
is saying this is a bad idea except for
the people who are saying no really come
with us come over to the farther left
side and that will make a big deal we'll
make a big deal out of it they're
basically writing off the middle class
and the blue-collar workers completely
writing them off you know 47 percent of
Americans have a four-year degree only
13 have graduate degrees but 50 percent
of the student loan debt is held by
people that have graduate degrees
graduate degrees so what happens to the
guy who took out a loan to get um you
know F-150 so that he could take his
Tools around that that's never going to
be canceled and it doesn't get canceled
it just gets transferred to somebody
else which is be they're transferring
the debt to the guy with the F-150 it is
also inflationary
why are we increasing why are we making
a move that would increase inflation at
this time why does that make any sense
it's also
um something that Congress should do so
this is an illegal move
it is unethical
it is immoral
and they're not going to get the
political payoff that they're looking
for they're not going to get the pr spin
they're just going to go through all the
policy pain and they're not going to
satisfy the left and they're not going
to satisfy anybody on the right you're
probably right about that so Tyrus if if
you got a graduate degree in philosophy
and you're making 124 000 a year in your
research well please you're going to get
some money paid off Socrates has said on
several occasions
if it floats like a duck then it's
probably a duck
I'm excited the fact at least he's
smartening up a little bit I I wish he
had the backbone he did 20 years ago or
even 10 years ago where he could
actually say hey this was a bad idea we
said it we're not going to do it so at
first it was all then it was 50. now
it's 10. so I figured by the end of next
week it'll be like 17.30 so he's just
gonna keep getting lower and lower and
lower and then he'll say look look what
I did guys I got you guys 14 cents back
on yours too because ten thousand
dollars on a student loan isn't anything
anyways so that's barely going to cover
the late fees because most of them
haven't paid it and the fact that it's
going to the 60 of the earners so that
the little guy once again is being
forced to pay for the big guy stuff so
what it really is it's like for his
lenders his donors here's a little
here's some money back and hopefully
he'll get it forward so so this was
Scranton Joe this was the middle class
guy with the lunch pail and the Amtrak
ticket does he even realize that he's
just helping out these graduate degree
I'm not going to say a bad word about
them
I I so I have I want to so badly though
I have a graduate degree in myself
yes and I took I took out loan Sean has
a law degree he took out loans it took
us 20 years we had nine kids who in
Congress is complaining the most about
these it's AOC he doesn't have any kids
um and she's complaining about the loan
she's agitating trying as you said Dana
get more people on her side I really
think our country needs to go back to
the place where your word your handshake
your signature meant something you
signed your name you said you were gonna
do it do it and you know what I will
tell you this it felt so good when we
paid it off but now I kind of feel like
a chump because they're going to get it
you know and by the way ten thousand
dollars is a lot I mean it's a lot of
money if somebody pays that off and
you're right the guy
for some people want more and people
still have to pay fair enough fair
enough I don't mean to disparage people
with graduate degrees I well actually
you meant only to disparage me
I have no graduate degrees everybody
else in my family has graduate degrees
except me but I'm the most successful
how about that
so oh my God financially successful
emotionally not so successful so tell us
why this is a good move
that was not my intention so this is a
bad move it is certainly the wrong time
for this move and I I'm fascinated by
the you know the game that goes on with
Larry Summers like yes he's God's gift
today he doesn't know what he's talking
about tomorrow he just so he was on
Barry Weiss's podcast over the weekend
and we were listening to it um on a car
ride yesterday and that sounds like a
fun run it was a long ride how long are
you gonna talk for anyway
um and he knows what place what role he
plays in this right he's become this
kind of Grandfather of democratic
politics obviously knows what he's
talking about and no one can point to
the Clinton years and say that they were
bad Republicans even liked the Clinton
years so he has these bonaf ideas to uh
to go on then obviously the Obama years
and then the fact that he pushed back
against build back better but was the
one who was tasked with personally
calling Joe manchin to say the skinny
Bill the inflation reduction Act is the
right thing to do and I think when
you're when you're on the Ascension and
Democrats are certainly doing better
than they were a month ago two months
ago and Biden's approval rating is even
ticking up it's above 40 percent now you
just delivered the biggest climate
action that we've had in American
history which is something that makes
the progressives the far left really
happy the Corey bushes of the world the
aocs that is enough heading into the
midterms when you bring something like
this up and it allows people in the
middle and certainly Republicans to
campaign on the idea that you're just
giving money back to the top 60 percent
of earners and it doesn't address the
root cause of the problem which is
tuition I mean institutions will have no
incentives to do anything about the fact
that they're it's like highway robbery
how much these degrees cost you just
brought up the the subsidies um or the
the tuition look at what happened with
the climate bill they said we're going
to give you a subsidy on electric
vehicles that same day yeah they raised
the price of the GM and four of those
Vehicles by the same amount as the
subsidy are you saying tuition prices
are going to go up ten thousand dollars
I mean when you look at how hard the
University's even pushed back against
the provisions in the bill that would
hold them a little bit more accountable
for the huge coffers that they're
sitting on I mean some private
institutions could pay make it free for
the rest of time that's how well Harvard
has managed their money and I know we're
not talking about Harvard because it
also this goes back to the fact that if
you look at polls ever since the Biden
Administration started do you think this
President cares about things that you
care about those his pulling on that has
been really bad and in this one when
you're looking just like fundamental
fairness for people who are out there
basically being told that the inflation
reduction Act is something great that
the gas and groceries are going to go
down in price when they realize oh
actually it was for all for climate
change they've I think that the
exacerbating feelings that there is the
problem as you said the little guy has
to pay for the big guy constantly you're
trying to solve the world with first
world problem solvers and most of us
live on down on the earth and we got to
deal with real stuff and that's about
that first world stuff so you have a
graduate degree I do not I'm with you
and I am the most successful person my
family thank you all right all your
relatives are really intended right now
my relatives
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now